are you guys ready for that Super Start
that comes in I am there you want to be
alright guys
obviously this show feels a little bit
like Game of Thrones and it's magical
and mystical are you ready for those
comparisons are you ready for it to be a
big success there's no escaping the fact
that people are gonna refer to compare
yes absolutely
um I mean both medieval shows both have
sword fighting the horses and many
complex characters but I think what the
running characters yeah so many guises
but I think our show is just it brings
they'll bring people together in the
entire family and watch it their
families come on [ __ ] hmm together and
it brings people together yeah well it
feels a little more wholesome so kind of
talked about that how you think it's
really different from what's out there
right now in terms of like why a content
fantasy content what sets it apart I
think a lot of the time when you watch
fantasy shows and you see kids battling
3 it feels like they get it kind of easy
and then if a kids done that that goes
no this is wrong adults just listen and
in reality they're not going to and
that's what all of these characters
struggle with trying to make the adults
see and listening to them and understand
that our points are actually quite valid
and rina really insightful drive
themselves because just because of the
fact that their kids so fun tomorrow
would be a good example yeah wish you
like fit on his son yeah I'm gonna make
like the younger novices feel so much
smaller and make himself feel so much
bigger and seem so much bigger and much
sleep
just exactly what that it will work
remember we've got her she's the most
ruthless scum of us all I meant by in a
good way
a lot of sword fighting horses how was
that for you guys I mean walk me through
kind of the training that you had to go
through training oh yeah no we was three
before and we had every day we had four
hours of boot camp just physical
training yeah yeah four hours of yeah
running yes sir yeah I think the basics
of sword fighting and then in the
afternoon we'd have an hour of horse
riding every day and that was for the
first three weeks yeah baby I don't you
paid off though yeah I hadn't done that
no you could've shot me show ya how do
your bodies feel at the end of that oh
there was some times we couldn't get on
the horses your legs
wake up exciting morning but this show
is obviously based on a book so how do
you think people who have read the book
what's your message to them what I would
say to especially to Dutch audiences
because it's really popular over there
it will look different I like to think
of it as we take a modern take on a
classic story and I think the message is
still very much the same we just try to
let it resonate with a with a modern
audience and I really think it pays off
because I read I read or my father read
the book to me when I was a child so
yeah I feel really proud about yeah I
really am
we've managed to keep the tone of the
book and just yes yes
bring it world I felt like in yeah they
in a series we introduced a lot more
characters in the book you kind of only
ready for of cheeriness the winds yeah
it's kind of boring that they're like oh
[Music]
now they're not boring cries and it's
good that we have more than what we have
more than one just storyline to follow
we have so many different people and you
get to follow each one and follow their
journey yeah well Davey's and the
writers and also Tonka to activate the
book collaborated did a really good job
of bringing female strong female
characters into it which is really
important especially for say for always
but some of the strongest characters in
the show are female let's talk a little
bit season to get a season 2 what do you
want to happen on the second book I hope
so
the second book is really cool as well
yeah yeah I read it after we finished
shooting because I just wasn't ready to
let go there's a wild secret the Bob
woods it's the secrets of the weapon yes
yes so I ran after and it's really cool
as well okay but actually we already in
the first season we were ready draw a
bit from the material the second book so
kind of just around well they just take
some things and I'll give it to you to
the audience earlier so I think there
are great opportunities to continue the
story is there a world where you guys
don't follow the books there too both
there are two books I think what
happened yeah I think Tong has given us
an incredible business yeah an
incredible starting point and the entire
world that she created in the books is
just so rich and there's so much to
explore yes I want to come from it yes
but at the same time the show is almost
its own
[Music]
for the moment saya I love the power in
you what powers is this shrimp got are
you guys ready for that super start that
comes I know I want to go home ONC I
don't really do what over here yes I
know but I'm not just because I want I
want to do my job I don't want to yeah
that's no you guys all agree no I am
there you want to be now you want to
live in a labor like that yeah sometimes
it's you know want to be chased by what
a private like yeah yeah it's so
important to them well opposite teams
after people do binge watch this once it
comes out what is your message to them
after watching that finale don't ya okay
first of all everyone you know yeah two
watches Oh like don't let other people
dictate who you are what you can be just
believe in yourself and find your own
path
yeah cliffhanger why is anything that
you want to tell them anything that's
gonna stress them out
oh you have to watch them say yes is you
up yeah yeah
[Music]